[Musique]
regardez ces magnifiques images de
l'épreuve d'endurance encore en cours
dans la baie du mont-sainmichel plus de
160 chevaux des cavaliers ont pris le
départ ce matin à 7h pour un parcours de
160 km des images magnifiques dont on ne
se lasse pas bonsoir soyez les bienvenus
sur le plateau de France I vasenormandie
ici au village des jeuxquestres mondu au
parc des expositions de camp nous sommes
au 4e jour de compétition une 4e journée
très riche et l'événement sans conteste
aujourd'hui flurent Turpin cétait cette
épreuve d'endurance encore en cours
d'ailleurs oui c'était l'un des
événements les plus attendus de ces 15
jours de compétition et regardez on
s'est régalé il faisait encore nuit ce
matin à l'aube dans le petit village de
sartillly dans la baie du montsmichel
quand ces 166 cavaliers venus de 48 pays
différents se sont élancés pour cette
épreuve d'endurance c'est le jour le
plus long de ces jeux équestre mondiaux
puisque l'endurance c'est un véritable
marathon équestre qui se déroule sur une
seule journée vous l'avez dit 160 km à
parcourir contre la montre et comme
décor les paysages somptueux de la baie
du monts-michel après un départ au Galot
pour éviter les bouchons les cavaliers
doivent ensuite gérer les efforts de
leurs chevaux parce que ces chevaux
doivent souvent régulièrement même se
soumettre à des contrôles vétérinaires
on verra ça plus en détail tout à
l'heure en endurance les grandes stars
ce sont les cavalers des pays du Golf on
voit ici à l'image les cataris qui ont
livré toute la journée une véritable
bagarre avec les cavaliers des émirat
arabes unis et après 11h de course
regardez c'est justement un concurrent
des Émirats arabes unis qui a franchi il
y a moins de 40 minutes la ligne
d'arrivée en tête à sartillli son nom
Aman Almou c'est tout simplement le fils
hritier de l'émire de Dubaï le prince
héritier de Dubaï je vous laisse
imaginer les moyens colossaux à sa
disposition pour remporter cette
médaille d'or en enduranceilie et on
n'oublie pas que les Français sont en
course en ce moment même pour essayer de
remporter une médaille par équipe oui on
suit peut-être qu'on voulait dans le
journal c'est ce qu'on souhaite André
Jacques leou bonsoir vous êtes notre
consultant la victoire
d'AM le le prince héritier de Dubaï
c'est pas une surprise non c'est pas une
surprise il était comme favori ce qui
est plutôt une surprise ses compatriotes
pour l'instant qui nont pas suivi qui
ont arrêté la course sont partis très
très vite à la grande surprise de tout
le monde et n'ont pas lu le livre et la
tortue à mon avis donc il finissent pas
la course les Français on y croit ils
sont tous dans la dernière boucle
actuellement français c'est bien il est
aux alentours de la 10e place si tout
bien ça continue comme ça peut-être qu'à
la fin du journal on aura une médaille
d'or ah on le souhaite alors dans cette
épreuve la gestion de la fatigue du
chevalier capital vous l'avez dit quatre
des cinq cavaliers des Émirats arabes
unis ont été éliminés ils ont été
recalés au contrôle vétérinaire car un
cheval trop fatigué peut-être exclu mais
ce contrôle vétérinaire c'est aussi un
gardef
qui permet de garantir l'intégrité du
cheval Pierre Marie pu
cy l'effort est très violent ce sont des
chevaux couverts d'écumes qui entrent
dans la zone de refroidissement des
marathoniens qui en terminent avec une
première boucle harassante 30 km au
Galot on a vraiment été doucement mais
on a a v des cheve on a
vu c'est dangereux quoi
c'est les Grou déversent des litres
d'eau fraîche sur les grosses artères
situées entre les jambes du cheval il
s'agit de faire tomber le rythme
cardiaque sous la limite imposée de 65
pulsations par
minute le chrono s'arrête VG la porte
des vétérinaires il contrôle la
respiration du cheval son atation ses
allures pour déceler une éventuelle
blessure et ce n'est pas une simple
formalité parce que le cheval est
éliminé au moindre doute que ce soit sur
un problème métabolique ou sur un
problème de locomotion bah preuve en est
que ici nous venons de perdre peut-être
notre meilleur
cheval alors que que on peut pas dire
qu' boî et bon voilà les vétérinaires
ont estimé que c'était pas
correct après l'examen vétérinaire les
chevaux sont bichonnés les cavaliers
reprennent leurs esprits ça va mieux oui
oui ça va je suis c'est une pause
imposée 40 minutes pour se refaire une
santé il est trs
[Musique]
bien alors Florent on l' redit des
images éblouissantes et nous avez concé
une petite sélection oui des super
images grâce notamment aux hélicoptères
présents autour du mont samichel on a
suivi cette épr minute par minute un peu
comme une épreuve d'une étape du Tour de
France c'était vraiment superbe on a
aussi vu pas mal de petites images
rigolotes regardez ce matin ce cheval
qui n'a visiblement pas très envie de se
soumettre au contrôle vétérinaire et il
le fait savoir un peu plus tard hop là
ce cavalier brésilien qui a un mal fou à
arrêter son cheval puis on l'a dit ce
sont les pays du golf qui dominent la
discipline regardez cet homme-là avec
son joli survêtement Bordeaux c'est tout
simplement l'un des hommes les plus
riches du monde le prince ou l'émir de
Dubaï venu encourager ses deux fils en
compétition les cavaliers de Dubaï
visiblement très à l'aise sur leurs
chevaux regardez celui-là se permet même
de passer un petit coup de téléphone
pendant la course peut-être Émilie à son
banquier on ne sait pas enfin même les
producteurs laitiers de la baie de
monts-michel ont soutenu l'équipe de
France d'Endurance avec des vaches aux
couleurs bleu blanc rouge ouis et
malheureusement dans cette épreuve il
faut signaler un cheval a trouvé la mort
une cavalière a été blessée Claudia
Romero une cavalière du Costa Rica chuté
ce matin elle a été blessée et
transporté d'urgence à l'hôpital son
cheval lui n'a pas survécu à cette chute
tragique après avoir heurté violemment
arbre André Jacques Le goupile ça
n'arrive ça n'arrive que rarement en
endurance une épreuve pourtant extrême
dieu merci parce que c'est une vraie
catastrophe on sait toujours pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé ce serait
tout simplement une sortie de route la
la française disait tout à l'heure
c'était très assez dangereux dans la
première partie très très ballonné il y
a pas ça de remarquer non c'est c'est
une catastrophe c'est très très rare on
a des entorses on a des problèmes
cardiaques parce que c'est marathon vous
l'avez dit mais ça jamais je crois que
c'est la première fois et c'est surtout
à l'obstacle dans les courses qu'il y a
le plus d'accidents oui tout à fait
j'espère que la cavalière va va mieux on
n' pas de nouvelles non plus alors
revenons à l'épreuve côté spectateur
5000 places avaient été vendu énormément
de personnes et bien se sont déplacé
pour assister à la course ce qui fait
que le parcours é déjàonné de
spectateurs regardez ce reportage de
Stéphanie Vinau et de Joë Hamar
si l'épreuve d'endurance a eu lieu dans
la région de sartillly c'est bien grâce
à lui le montsmichel a servi de décor au
cavalier la pointe du grin du Sud
offrait ce matin un panorama
exceptionnel les spectateurs avertis ne
s'y sont pas trompés c'est ici qu'il
fallait être pour le passage de la
deuxième boucle il y a un paysage
fantastique en plus bon il y a le mon
Saint-Michel derrière nous et les Ch
arrivent parosition ils arrivent face à
nous et après on se déplace on les a
avec le mont samichel derrière je crois
que c'est des photos ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on arrive à
approcher les concurrents d'assez près
voir les les chevaux on a le temps de
les admirer au passage c'est un beau
spectacle quand on pense qu'ils vont
faire 160 km c'est quand même
impressionnant les les cavaliers par
contre sont assez légers ça m'a surpris
je pensais qu'il y aurait plus de jour
dans les 80 kg donc c'est c'est comme
une compétition qui est
réservé à des gens plutôt légers quoi et
pour voir de près les cavaliers il y
avait encore les points de
ravitaillement si c'était réparti sur
les 160 km de l'épreuve les chevaux y
prenaient une pause de quelques petites
minutes pour se rafraîchir je trouve que
les chevaux sont magnifiques alors je
suis étonné c'est la l'écart qu'il y a
entre les entre les différents
concurrents il y a 25 minutes entre les
entre le premer et le 4e et le 3e les
écarts sont extrêmement extrêmement
importants nous chens qu'on est ça dans
notre région donc on se doit d'être là
pour voir tout ça voir aussi les autres
pays et voir les chevaux qui sont quand
même magnifique et voilà toute la
journée les chevaux ont traversé la
campagne ainsi que les plages du
sudmanche un beaucoup de projecteurs sur
la région visible un peu partout dans le
monde et sur notre site Internet vous
pouvez faire plus ample connaissance
avec l'équipe d'endurance du Kazakhstan
qui s'est entraîné en fait dans le
Perche pendant 3 semaines sur notre site
donc bastirnormandie.france3.fr
Emmanuel chunu voilà vous avez fait un
dessin pour Almou et son fils qui a donc
remporté le lor en individuel le prince
héritier ça va lui plaire je suis sûr
autre épreuve qui a démarré aujourd'hui
le concours complet le triathlon du
cheval qui se déroule en trois épreuves
le dressage le cross et le sa d'obstacle
et donc aujourd'hui c'était la première
journée du dressage sur la belle
carrière qui a été construit pour les
Jeux équestres au aras duupin Florent
oui et en attendant donc le cross et le
saut d'obstacle qui auront lieu dans les
prochains jours c'était donc au AR
duupin et dans des tribunes à guichet
fermé et oui c'est assez rare depuis le
début jeuxquestres mondiaux et tous les
regards étaient braqués sur une
cavalière anglaise on va la voir à
l'image elle s'appelle Zara Philips son
nom ne vous dit sûrement rien mais c'est
la petite fille de la reine d'Angleterre
et mamie risque d'être déçue car Zara
Philipe ça réalisé ce matin sous la
pluie un passage très moyen André
Jacques leoup mon petit doigt me dit que
vous avez suivi le parcours de
l'américaine chinalpine et de son cheval
bien de chez nous oui en 19e ce matin
elle a très très bien débuté sa reprise
malheureusement il est arrivé quelque
chose fallait absolument pas que ça
arrive un jour de championnat du monde
mais arriv d' son cheval c'est manoir de
kerneville qui est né à Martin va dans
l'élevage de votre papa mais était
parfait et chinette s'est trompé dans sa
reprise un petit mot sur les Français
très mauvais début avec avec Pascal
Leroi qui passait en numéro 3 sous les
trompes d'eau il a jamais fait autant de
fautes et Il se les juge
lui-même Pascal très belle reprise de
Cédric lard qui était dans l'équipe
championne olympique à athèà pour
l'instant et puis on retrouvera demain
je maime livot pour l'équipe et puis ça
mauvaise prestation de rodol on y
reviendra demain et pour assister à
cette épreuve les premiers spectateurs
sont arrivés à 5h du matin ils ont bien
fait pourquoi et bien parce que le
comité d'organisation avait tout
simplement fermé la majorité des
parkings grand public qui étai inondé
par la pluie l'idée c'est de préserver
avant le rush du cross samedi Aurée
miser Damien
mign ça patine pour ce Parisien la faute
à la pluie qui transforme les parkings
en herbage en champ de bout à tel point
que dans la matinée l'accès à c de
stationnement est
fermé il est
impraticable qu' est tombé là les
voitures pour pasessortir
après prévoyez pas des parkings qui
supportent la que Normandie c'est pas
faire un J la Normandie mais sincèrement
je trve d'organisation c'est pas
au AR duupupin sur les 61 hectares de
parking seul C ont pu être ouverts au
public fermé aujourd'hui les parkings
sur l'arbe justement pour préserver pour
que samedi on puisse accueillir nos
50000 spectateurs dans les meilleures
conditions pour préserver les parkings
les automobilistes ont été aujourd'hui
réorientés vers la départementale 26 où
ils se sont garés en longue file
indienne résultat ce couple devra
marcher de bons kilomètres pour
rejoindre l'entrée du bar duup dans la
VO étais un peu énervé mais on prend
avec le sourire maintenant rien faire
contre la météo gardons le sourire car
après quelques averses passag vu encore
ce soir météo France annonce le retour
d'un temps soleillé dès demain matin des
conditions plus agréables pour les 50000
spectateurs attendus samedi aux épreuves
de cross alors nous sommes toujours au
direct du village des jeux Florent
Turpin il y av également du raining
aujourd'hui deè tour des qualifications
individuelles le repêchage jour de
repêchage au parc des expositions de
camp puisque les all recalé du premier
tour avait une autre occasion de se
qualifier pour la grande finale deuxème
chance notamment pour les Français que
seul romeal poar a su saisir vous le
voyez à l'image romal poard qui sera
donc le seul représentant français dans
cette finale de rainning samedi c'est
assez inespéré écoutez-le au micro de
Corine
bianrosa il y a un peu de pression quand
même je l'avoue le le là le monde il y a
la foule il y a tout ça donc moi
j'aiessayé de mettre ça un peu à l'écart
euh la pression est sortie après euh
toujours un petit peu d'émotion mais non
non j'avais un bon cheval et j'ai fait
j'ai fait confiance enfin alors il y
avait également du paradressage
aujourd'hui Florent et ce soir on va
suivre particulièrement l'Autrichien
peppo pouche drôle d'histoire pour ce
cavalier autrichien peppo pouche le
voici sur ces images il y a 10 ans en
2004 il disputait les Jeux Olympiques
d'athèn avec les valides mais en 2008 il
est victime d'un grave accident de
cheval qui le laisse paraplégique
pourtant 3 ans plus tard il revient à la
compétition avec le même cheval celui
donc avec lequel il a eu cet accident et
le voici de retour dans ses compétitions
de paradressage au plus haut niveau ici
à camp pour ces jeux équestre mondieu
c'est un cavalier de complet he pppo
pouche maintenant par adressage un coup
d'œil sur le programme demain petite
journée demain Ilie qui commence à 9h
par du paradressage à l'hippodrome de
camp puis place au concours complet au
haradupin avec encore l'épreuve de
dressage et puis à 13h30 au stade
d'Ornano début de la reprise libre en
musique pour les 15 meilleurs de
dressage on suivra ça merci FL alors le
nom d'oltech est associé à ces 7è
jeuxquestres mondiaux vous ne pouvez pas
le le louper cette entreprise américaine
spécialisée dans la nutrition animale a
mis 10 millions d'euros pour être le
principal sponsor de ces jeux son but
c'est de se développer en Europe dans la
première spécialité normande l'élevage
bovin et ils ouvrent une antennevire à
l'effigie d'EM rovit c'est l'une de leur
marque reportage de Rémy Moget de
l'ïlash les voilà les bénéficiaires du
généreux Mesen des jeux équestres et
dans le bocage virois tout est fin prêt
pour les servir une équipe d'une dizaine
de personnes a pris possession des
locaux au printemps dernier et
aujourd'hui c'est le boss du team France
qui nous accueille en affichant ses
ambition dis on est 10 là on sera 20
entre 25 et 30 l'année prochaine et puis
ensuite 20 plus tous les an tous
derrière Mister lions le charismatique
père fondateur de la société depuis 30
ans c'est un visionnaire et un
entrepreneur incroyable et aujourd'hui
c'est réellement le Steve Jobs de la
nutrition animale big mais compil donc à
vendre pour nourrir les bêtes cet
éleveur de pointe ne les connaiss pas il
y a quelques mois il fait partie des
nouveaux
adeptes je sais pas mais on recherche
toujours des nouvelles technologies
pourer la digestion la rumination
des lait il est fait une bonne
rumination une bonne alimentation en
fait c'est de l'azote trs retard ça
coûte cher au kilo mais ça permet de
diminuer les rations il est presque
convaincu non c'est pas adopté mais
c'est essayé c'est conclu ce que l'on
constate c'est 100 € minimum par vache
par an gagner ou d'économiser il faut
qu'on reprenne les échantillon de lait
le taux ça se fait pas du jour au
lendemain on va pas dire c'est
miraculeux ça marche pas ça marche c'est
sûr maintenant le coût financier je l'ai
pas c'est pas fait et on n pas encore
tout vu Altech emrovit et compagnie ont
une gamme de produits existant ou cours
de recherche leur science favorite
s'appelle la nutrigénomique elle entend
lutter contre les OGM et les
antibiotiques avec un bon marketing ça
fait son effet à l'exemple de cette
ferme du futur surtout n'ayez pas peur
elle a pour ambition de réunir V et
campagne producteur et consommateur ça
fait rêver non
ouis il y aura bientôt les Jeux mondiaux
bovvin Emmanuel CHU les jeux équestres
côté développement économique on en
parle avec vous François Xavier lefran
bonsoir vous êtes récteur en chef des
rédactions de West France vous organisez
lundi prochain les premières assistes de
la finière Kin pourquoi dans quel but B
tout simplement parce que derrière les
les images magnifiques qu'on vient de
voir il faut se Rapp qu'il y a une
filière économique qui pèse énormément
qui crée des emplois pour la seule
Normandie hautbas c'est à peu près 17000
emplois la région voisine des Pays de la
Loire c'est 10 1100 et ce qu'on a voulu
rappeler c'est que c'est un très fort de
l'économie des régions notre volonté
c'est de réunir tous les acteurs de la
filière cheval ils sont nombreux c'est
une grande famille avec beaucoup de
diversité avec des des des je dirais des
catégories qui beaucoup de diversité
d'où la difficulté de fédéré jusqu'à
présent voilà exactement c'était jamais
fait il y a des gens dans la filière qui
souhaitaent que ça se fasse je voudrais
juste citer un nom c'est celui de
paulessartial qui est un éleveur que que
que beaucoup connaissent qui fait
référence qui a au niveau national
organisé les les conseils des chevaux de
Normandie et c'est en discutant avec lui
en discutant aussi avec laurenceier qui
est présidente du pôle du pôle de
le seul en France et qui est ici en en
Normandie on a eu l'idée donc de réunir
tous les responsables économiques de
montrer ce que pèse cette filière et là
on va organiser des débats des
réflexions avec des spécialistes et
c'est un événement qu'on souhaite
maintenant organiser chaque année euh
pour permettre à cette filière de se
développer et ça permettra aux gens et
sans doute à des gens qui se voient
rarement parce que la famille est
parfois un peu éclatée ça leur permettra
de se retrouver au moins une fois par an
euh pour parler de cheval pour que
projets naissent l'idé c'est ça bien sûr
il y a beaucoup de projets euh et puis
on pense que c'est toujours intéressant
quand des professionnels se retrouvent
pour faire des affaires pour imaginer
les choses monter des projets c'est
vraiment la volonté qu'on a au France de
d'aider l'économie de la région à
travers le cheval pour rassembler les
mondes du cheval merci beaucoup François
Xavier lefan alors on vous les a
présenté hier cette image des Amazon et
bien aujourd'hui elles ont fait des
démonstrations de puissance en sautant
des bares donc avec les deux jambes du
même côté elles ont commencé à 80 cm
aller jusqu'à 1,30 bravo à elle on va
maintenant retrouver dans le village des
jeux où on a pu voir ses amazones cet
après-midi hélè Jacques euh hen ça fait
6 jours que le village a ouvert ses
portes et vous avez cherché à savoir ce
que pense ce que pens les visiteurs de
ce village bonsoir Ilie bonsoir à tous
et bien déjà je peux vous dire qu'il y a
du monde hein tous les jours ici et ça
va en augmentant on parle de 10000
personnes par jour depuis le début de la
semaine 13 mliard selon les
organisateurs et cet après-midi les
allées étaient noir de monde orors des
gens bien sûr passionn don des
quitations mais pas seulement exemple
clair vous êtes de camp alors pourquoi
est-ce que vous êtes venu vous êtes pas
du tout de ce monde là vous non du tout
mais je suis venu par curiosité alors
impression impression magnifique et
c'est adorable à voir qu'est-ce qui vous
plaît le plus là ici euh bah tous les
stands les spectacles et surtout la
cérémonie d'ouverture que j'ai été voir
ah oui vous avez eu la chance d'aller
voir la cérémonie d'ouverture il y a
beaucoup de monde en ce moment dans les
allées parce qu'il y a les cavaliers qui
sont là les cavaliers qui viennent de
Kings valallleé d'Orléan comme
Christophe ou encore des cavaliers qui
sont derrière les cowboys qui viennent
de flair et donc je peux vous dire que
ces cavaliers bah sont en démonstration
dans les carrières tous les jours ici
sur le village GEM c'est gratuit et puis
une petite précision quand même depuis
aujourd'hui entre 11h et 14h les
visiteurs n'ont pas à débourser les 5 €
obligatoires pour le village voilà ce
que je peux vous dire Ie merci Hélène
Jacques un peu de musique maintenant
dans le village des jeux toujours avec
ces sonneurs de trompe de chasse les
échos du pays d'aue pouzrouver TR à qu
fois par jour sur le village un
instrument qui sert pour la chasse à
cour et c'est au son des trompes de
chasse vous annon chronique de matthie
bellingan les dans le crotin ce soir il
a essayé en marge de l'épreuve
d'endurance de se faire inviter dans la
tente de l'M de Duba r ça alors nous
sommes au village départ de la course
d'endurance à sartill dans la Manche il
y a des tes partout il a des très
intéressant d'ailleurs il y a celle du
CH al qui derrière moi on va aller voir
si on peut rentrer voir ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur parceelle fait je crois
presque 1000
m c'est une tente mais est équipé double
vitrage pas mal pour du
camping peuton visiter la tente pour la
télévision
française on va carrément aller voir
ente du prince
lu nous sommes une équipe de télévision
française Normandie et on voudrait
filmer
l'intérieur on va essayer de voir si
rentre dans la
tente
bonjouril voulez pas qu'on filme on
voudrait rentrerir un du
tout mais finement Pr et tout ça
snob fr s'il vous
plaît merci al rien de mieux que la
simplicité Mathieu allez on va parler
maintenant d'une discipline en
démonstration au José castre mondiaux il
s'agit du horse ball et il y avait une
sacrée ambiance hier soir à saintlo
Alexandra htin
Sylvain quand on vous dit que ça
ressemble au basket c'est une réalité
jusqu'au pom pom girl le Horseball c'est
un véritable mélange de show et de sport
avant même l'entrée des équipes sur le
TER ça chauffe dans les tribunes
font monter la mayonnaise et quand on
arrive après c'est chaud et ça nous
soutient la magie du Horseball c'est
donc au-delà de la technique et du
couple hommecheval alors bien sûr les
initiés apprécieront la vitesse la
réactivité du cavalier sa monture quand
il faut s'imposer pour les marquer mais
c'est le jeu aussi qui
captive c'est vivant ça va beaucoup plus
vite que le polo par exemple c'est
SC de jeu sont sont faciles à comprendre
même pour
desop c'est comme un
sport comme du basket hand c'est facile
àer c'est
trèsque et comme ici le
public comparaison avec les disciplin de
l'équitation une fois de foisali
cavalier je m'ennuyais tandis que le
même si on connait pas ça bouge
c'estpique et puis il y a les speakers
leur langage et le vocabulaire qu'ils
inventent sans relâche le Horb affiche
complet dans les tribunes pendant 4
jours maintenant vous savez
pourquoi il c'est encore en cour jusqu'à
22h Emmanuel Chenu des leall ça vous
inspir voilà vous connaissez le horse
ball et puis maintenant il y a le HORSE
qui va se dérouler sur les parkings du
arat du pain voilà les pieds dans l'eau
les sabots dans l'eau et on a un
spécialiste de ça c'est une nouvelle
discipline ça va marcher du feu de de
Dieu hein le rose ball c'est on le doit
en français c'est c'est né il y a une
trentaine d'années inventé par Jean-Paul
de pont c'est c'est effectivement un
super sport collectif et super rock and
roll bon on se quitte sur ces belles
images mais avant un grand merci à
toutes les équipes techniques de France
3 bas en Mandi et de France Télévision
sport je peux vous dire que ils font un
super travail depuis 6 jours on les
salue euh demain à midi focus sur le
Horseball justement avecac on vous
expliquera un peu mieux les règles
parlera de la grande équipe d'Agon
coutinville à 19h ce sera Sylvain RU et
moi je vous dis à ce weekend pour nos
superbes émissions spéciales qu'on vous
concocte merci messieurs très bonne
[Musique]
soirée